netz kursiert jetzt ein video das zeigen
soll wie es überhaupt zu diesem sturm
auf den reichstag kommen konnte zu sehen
ist eine frau auf der bühne direkt vor
dem reichstag sie hetzt die
demonstranten auf behauptet die
polizeibeamten würden jetzt alle ihre
helme absetzen und donald trump wäre für
einen blitzbesuch in der hauptstadt
angekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass dieser rede stürmten circa 400
chaoten den reichstag und schwenken
unter anderem die sogenannte reichs
frage in schwarz weiß rot wie sie die
reichs bürger verwenden nur eine
handvoll von polizisten gelang es den
wütenden mob von eindringen in das
gebäude fernzuhalten bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier dem wir gerade
auch gehört haben hatte die situation
verurteilt und sagte rice flaggen und
rechtsextreme pöbeleien vor dem
deutschen bundestag sind ein
unerträglicher angriff auf das herz
unserer demokratie das werden wir
niemals hinnehmen erklärte steinmeier